um the Angolan Revolution the the
Angolan reached independence in 1975 and
at that time there were three
organizations one was called the MPLA
the movement for the popular movement
for the liberation of Angola the FNLA
and I'm going to get these names
straight and you need to at all three
were FNLA was operated pretty much in
the north you need to operate pretty
much in the south and the MPLA operated
throughout the whole country and
independence in November of 1975 South
Africa invaded now at this time most
people it wasn't sure which organization
which group that they supported but in
1975 when the MPLA which was the
government Portugal goes up was a
Portuguese calling Portugal pulled out
MPLA formed a government at that time
also South Africa invaded from the South
is a air invaded from the north with the
iron vated from the north along with
FNLA troops South Africa invaded from
the south along with UNITA troops so
this made it clear for most people you
know which was the true liberation
movement and a CIA poured a lot of funds
into the into lon Angola the CI went in
tangora in July of 1975 we started out
with six million dollars eventually the
total budget was 31 million dollars the
first effort was arms that were sent
from America to Kinshasa in US air force
c-141 plane and then from Kinshasa we
hold the arms and Tony Boland smaller
the total is about 1,500 tons of arms
30,000 rifles and small rockets and
mortars our funds and arms were going to
two of the three angola factions one of
them hit it up by Holden Roberto who had
had a relationship with us for about 15
years and to Savini who had not been
well known by the CIA he had the sole
virtue of being in opposition to the
MPLA and we were determined to oppose
president Mobutu as a year wanted this
program we bribed we gave or $2,750,000
CIA officers went in as advisors and
trainers they were called intelligence
gatherers but in fact they were
preparing our allies for combat well
Diego fujita-san paladar from the
addresses I fled to San Salvador on
January 16th already with hey Ilan what
did the enemy do in San Salvador Oh
nuki guilty ie you mean what I saw how
long he knows I'm a con
the Americans were there I'm a canteen
how do you know they were Americans he
succumbed Odyssey Americans take a
quantity arrow lap when the villagers
saw them with their own eyes they saw
they were Americans Museum worship under
the air were 20 American tea how many
times I may be gonna fool these
Americans what did they look like with a
light were they black today describe
them now I look more I thought oh my god
they were your color comrade hey Twyla
caught it no no I don't read they were
not black well they had chestnut eyes
you know white there were not enough CIA
advisors to make a great deal of
difference however and we hired European
mercenaries and we tried to hire white
Angolan refugees to go back and his
mercenaries fighting on our side
the CIA collaborated with the South
African and it was not officially
ordered by the National Security Council
but there was lettuce on it all
CIE was nervous about the role the
Senate might play in this war senator
Clark on the Foreign Relations Committee
made a trip to Africa to review the
situation back tire 340 Senate C I
watched him with some apprehension to
see that he didn't get information we
didn't want him to have the Senate led
by Senator Clark shut down the angola
program in December of 75 well the
Senate was shutting us down
Cuban army eventually of ten to fifteen
thousand combat soldiers actually one
aircraft tanks and just swept over the
FNLA and UNITA and we lost decisive so
dia a victory over the other Africa that
will change the course of African
history Bobby
so do than annoy the victory of the
heroic people of Angola Cuba had a long
history of support for African
liberation I don't want to go into that
might take a little too much time but
they supported in a Congo with Lumumba
they they they worked with different
groups in just all over Africa in terms
of African liberation Che Guevara was
working with some African liberation
exact movements in fact a lot of Cubans
are black that a lot of the Cubans
originally were slaves who came over
from Africa to work on the Spanish sugar
cane plantations so they have roots
there and they still maintain the the
culture of the so-called mother country
an interesting thing is that what I was
reading one thing is really true they
said one of the most interesting
paradoxes of history is that if the
slave traders knew that that the people
that they were taking over you know to
Cuba you to cut sugarcane and slaves
we're going to come back centuries later
and help liberate that territory they
were just they know what to do but
anyhow so then the situation is that the
MPAA government is backed up into the
capital Luanda there's two major armies
one coming from the south
South Africa put one of the the biggest
tank brigades together since World War
two you know to attack and also from the
north now South Africa had has still the
most modern army on the shores of Africa
so so of course they felt like this was
going to be a cakewalk
you know they felt like that it was
going to be just a few weeks that they
were going to take Luanda they're never
going to back up and set up a you need a
government the MPLA government asks for
help
sit on a call for help actually a lot of
countries came to help the major country
was Cuba they they they discussed it and
they decided that if if South Africa
took Angola that all of Africa would be
it would have to deal with a party and
and and it would destabilize more and
more borders so the African countries
also supported Cuba coming that's just
important point to make so Cuba sent
over about 40,000 troops or so to stop
the South African invasion they the
South Africans at this time were right
outside of Luanda but you know before
the Cubans could come they have done a
tremendous amount of damage you know to
the Angolan countryside you know moving
all the way up Cubans stopped them in
the engl and stopped them another
important point is that the the MPLA
army was a guerrilla army which is
totally I don't know if your viewers are
into tactics of war but you know hold
man you trying to hold trying to land
your gorilla arm the different
techniques only dodgy so they really
didn't even know how to do to fight the
South Africans air and you need to
indefinitely okay so so the Cuban army
comes in stops the attack and pushes
South Africa all the way back to the
borders of Namibia which is pretty
amazing a small country like Cuba taking
a giant like South Africa which was
supported by the CIA the United States
and pushing it back and put their troops
back to up to the north and then the
South Africans immediately wanted to
negotiate and they were to negotiate
because they knew that that the force
that had been put together could have
went right into the midea and liberated
Namibia vent but but but they they
stopped at the Namibian
in negotiating South Africa said that
they would stay this should be at the
Demilitarized Zone on both sides of the
Angolan border in the middle and they
would pull back
of course what happened was they did
they continually invaded they continued
invaded and kept in invading up till you
know last year so that that that's the
historical situation I can if you want
talk about some of the current well
that's where interesting and what's been
going on in the last year or two to try
to normalize yeah there is the the South
Africans are saying they want to
negotiate again I wouldn't trust him
right right right on both points South
Africa's want to negotiate again and of
course people wonder why is that why all
of a sudden the South Africans want
peace in Angola and in and also are
ready to sign the UN resolution for 3/5
giving independence to Namibia which it
will sure put in a swap of government
Southwest there's a lot of this
government yeah and it's so government
today would have been trying to stop
since they have been in in the Libyan
well the point is this in November of
first of all South Africa's continued
invaded and and there have been how the
defense of Angola has been over since 75
is they have built up three lines of
defense the ethanol I mean am the FOP
low troops which is the Angolan army
three lines of defense and then behind
them the Cubans are the Cubans sit back
and have really have not really been in
battle since 7576 yes the table troops
you know are so good now that they have
been able to stop South Africa the South
Africa troops have never been able to
get to the third line of defense the
second line has always stopped us all
having troops but South Africa decided
that the balance of forces were such
that they wanted because they were
afraid that that SWAPO was going to get
independence from the maybe and a lot of
things were happening around Africa and
they were even destabilizing more
countries more oh Mozambique type in
Teheran Mosin bleeding Mozambique to
death
their own Contras right all right and
they've been the soothe loose you know
Swaziland of Botswana they've been going
to all these countries you know at will
so they decided they see software
understands that that the most important
country in southern Africa right now is
Angola and they wanted to destabilize
Angola more than any other country so
what they decided was they put their
hopes on attacking a small town which
was a center of the MPLA military it was
called quitter carnival and they were
going to move the Angolans out of wheat
or carnival put UNITA in and which is
headed by Savimbi that young guy has
been to the United States see how
everybody is South African connection
okay CIA has been supporting this event
you know since before 75 even though he
says he's a Marxist right scaris manitto
says whatever whoever he talking to I
said that's what he hears Christian he's
a Marxist he this you know he's an
opportunist yeah big opportunists okay
as a matter of fact that you know one of
the things that it's really clear is the
CIA and the United States government
support you needed through a lot of fun
in by supporting you need their support
in South Africa we can't decide it
without asking South Africans we can't
decide it without asking the Americans a
lot of the weapons that go to UNITA end
up in South African hands anyhow they
wanted to take this this town called
cuido Colonel off and make it a you need
a stronghold and then you need it was
going to declare a government you know
in and and and then ask for South
African help if they were attacked so
that was a plan so it's all be like a
very good plan so they the South
Africans moved in across the river we
took on evolves on a river and started
bombarding and staging we took on a row
and this happened to November they the
sage was went from November to March
remember of 87 to march of 88 that there
was a siege they attacked the city at
least once a month with major attacks
coming in January February and March
the try to break and push the MPLA out
of quita carnival the Angolans again
asked the Cubans for assistance
because they realized that this was the
most serious attempt at breaking their
sovereignty at that has happened since
75 so they asked the Cubans for help
the Cubans talked about it discussed it
and decided that it was so important
that they not take this time that they
not only there were about forty thousand
cubic troops already in Angola that so
that they not only wanted to move those
Cuban troops into bound but they sent
twelve thousand of their best troops of
there that were in Cuba to Angola this
was a very complex undertaking
particularly from the logistics point of
view
they gotta go for the court for this
operation the Cuban army will only take
volunteers each person is interviewed to
see if they have any personal objections
to being a volunteer or if they have any
home problems or psychological problems
which would prevent them from
volunteering Hamas mama neora in salute
Regas Movember anniversary dissemble
Quadra caso de caso no Pantone emission
color mondo superior donation
internationally the term international
ista is a very special one in Cuba
people who volunteer for overseas duty
of any type whether military or health
workers or education are called
international Easter's and you know
Moochie internationally
the equipment was also brought to the
ports by rail into people delusion
infected people they the commanding
general of the troops in Angola gives an
orientation and welcoming speech la 7 e
dot d rossabi Lauria allow the one who
does the general reconfirmed a voluntary
nature of the operation and asks if each
of the soldiers is volunteered by allah
we narrate an advanced contingent of
troops is sent over by airplane these
are people from the Cuban Special Forces
the bulk of the troops and their
equipment are sent by ship to Angola as
big as it proved it all must be
minocycline the units of the Special
Forces will be sent to the action area
where the situation is most critical at
cuido Carnivale itself this is the area
that the South Africans are attacking
and it is about 1,000 kilometers from
the airport in Luanda next is the South
African attack
these are the South African airplane
these are the Cubans defending quick
token evolve
these Cuban make airplanes in the hands
of the Cuban pilots turned out to be
decisively superior to those of the
South Africans the only airport in
Angola was at Luanda there were three
ports however to receive the ships the
last two were in the southern part of
the country still about a thousand
kilometers from the war zone itself
transporting the metamaterial to this
area was a Herculean task
the trek to the war zone begins so so
now there's 50 mm you know Cuban troops
an angle they so nice it and Fidel
Castro actually said that because they
sent these 12 thousand troops it called
the defenses of their own country into
question they had that their defenses
weren't as good because they sent these
twelve thousand troops it wasn't just
the fact that the roads in this
underdeveloped country were very
primitive and very few there were also
losses and delays caused by mined roads
those mines which are laid by Savimbi's
forces and also a lot of bridges had
been blown up by the guerrillas and by
the South Africans and added to all this
was the fact that this was occurring
during the spring floods and so a lot of
bridges were washed out as well as those
which were demolished and blown up by
the guerrilla forces nonetheless the
Cubans did an amazing job of forging all
of these areas by passing some areas and
where this was impossible their
engineers actually repaired and rebuilt
the bridges themselves another
monumental task of engineering and
construction was building an airstrip
which was close enough to the battle
zone for close support tactical
operations for the troops auda ustedes
Iran testigos de otra gran go bruh
construct Eva poi totalmente conclude
Eva
said that after the unify stopped a
lobbyist you'll be the constructions
made well enough so they could be used
well into the future not just for the
immediate needs of the battle zone
itself by working around the clock the
cubans completed the airstrip in only
six weeks the cubans claimed that the
south africans were caught off guard and
surprised by the short time it took for
them to build the airstrip the cuban air
power had a devastating effect on the
south africans
KTU for low my musical director she
physical meanwhile back in Havana Fidel
Castro was examining every detail of
what was going on and this scene he was
talking to his supply officer asking him
where he's getting the food they're
buying Angolan tuna and also wondering
about why there are so many coals among
the soldiers suggesting that they should
be sending more vitamin C to the truth
they play all interval the zygomatic but
it was working she poked in the eye yeah
Castro also questioned very closely this
tank commander who just came back from
the battles he suggests some changes in
tactics meanwhile some of the soldiers
who have arrived at the war zone start
preparing defensive position
got me more
da da da da
nothing
ha
the troops receive not only military
briefing and information but also a
political indoctrination as to why
they're there and what they're supposed
to be doing meanwhile the soldiers wait
prepare their positions with the help of
some automated equipment which builds
the trenches for them they prepared
their machinery and get ready for battle
gasps bio infi Logan is a woman who is
the head of the medical unit front says
it's not only important to have medical
facilities available it also it's good
for morale to have women there
Yente mm privacy las condiciones de vida
enough are the facilities which the
Cubans have for medical assistance and
treatment near the front I suppose is
equivalent to our mass units in the
Korean War and here is what the patients
would find in a city
before going into battle they Angola
troops entertain the Cuban troops
from the end of January throughout
February the South Africans attack
trying to break the lines of the
Angolans the fapla troops which were
east of cui toe can evolve
the heavy attacks by the South Africans
caused severe losses to the Angola
troops which at one time in one
significant sector only had eight tanks
left to face the South Africans but the
Angolans held particularly with the help
of the fresh Cuban troops this is
vitally important because the main
thrust of the Cuban attack was going to
be to the west and to the south of the
city to meet the South Africans at the
Namibian border rather than passively
receive the South African attacks and
then counter-attack
there was a lot of heavy fighting from
the end of January throughout February
with South Africa attacking several
times and the Cubans gradually pushing
them toward the south
the Cubans particularly had the
advantage in detective equipment such as
radar sound detection and also in
control of the air with the Cuban planes
vastly outperforming those of the South
Africans driving them from the sky
forest received a terrible loss
resistance avian cambiado attack as a
result of this the South Africans change
their tactics basically they did not
make any day attacks anymore because
they had no air superiority or a chance
of surprise
so they started launching a series of
night attacks the South Africans still
figured they had technological
superiority and so they attack
repeatedly in February
Lucido for orders forming one such
attack the South Africans began at four
in the morning
attacking the poplar troops on the flank
of the Cubans trying to turn the flank
and driving a wedge between them but the
attack was beaten off throughout this
battle which lasted more than four hours
los combat ace de Sevilla say Pro longer
inform SDO see auras
let's assume that I'm with the commander
of the Cuban troops in Angola reviewed
the situation now next day with his
battle weary troops yeah but I love it
what they just it's train of war can be
seen in their steps than in their faces
Samuel Lara what is it though that today
still believing they had superior
equipment the South Africans continued
to attack into march they did have
excellent artillery and that was causing
the Cubans and the Angolan some problems
the South Africans thought that their
tanks were superior to those of the
Cubans but this turned out not to be the
case
sankaranna while I see Bella trouble as
the lines held the creature can't evolve
the Cubans and golems and SWAPO troops
push to the south toward the new Libyan
border and into that country at the same
time they also attack South Africa on
two other fronts you know Quinta
Carnival is more in the eastern part in
the western part they also attacked and
the army consisted of fapla which is a
very good army now of the Cuban troops
of SWAPO the liberation organization in
namibia and the anc the liberation
organization in South Africa so actually
what you had was a liberation army of a
number of countries a number of
liberation movements and countries
coming together to defeat a party in
South Africa the leader of SWAPO the
Namibian resistance had this to say in a
speech SWAPO and the its military wing
the People's Liberation Army of namibia
plan has created confidence in the
masses of the Namibian people that they
are self free burritos so the struggle
would it be intensified and filled all
the forces of fascism colonialism as it
is presented in our offended by the
bottle gym are wiped out and this is our
power becomes a reality in a movie they
push it all the way back to the Namibian
border and again South Africa wanted
negotiate but this time it was even up
it was more of a major defeat than last
time and the reason is that Cuba brought
over and Angola had something called
mig-23s these Jets that South Africa
vivid that Soviet Union you know gave to
Cuba will actually Cuba bottom and and
also angle about some they were know the
meat that the Mirage Jets that that
South Africa bought from France were no
match for these the South Africa also
has these really big tanks that they
call elephants these elephant takes
scare people because they're really big
nerd really loud but there are no
mattress smaller more accurate Soviet
tanks they were picking off tanks like
that you got into a Soviet
South Africa tink that was like a death
wish just like a mirage jet it was a
death wish because he was no way that
you could you could you could you could
live so so they were knocking out all
all of South Africa's major weapon
systems what happened in this battle was
that South Africa also attacked with
what's called a Namibian territorial
militia that these are black troops that
South Africa was using as cannon fodder
these troops rebelled a halt and refused
to fight because they realized what what
the deal was so South Africa had to move
up it's white troops and so what South
Africa was began to have to deal with is
a lot of white troops were getting
killed their planes were getting knocked
out of the sky it couldn't send up a
plane the troops were getting beat
really bad so the white South Africans
were getting killed by the you know you
know dozens or scores or whatever and so
and the interesting thing was that all
of a sudden within South Africa a
resistance movement get began to develop
for the draft people began to say I'm
not going into the army sounds like the
United States and Vietnam we're
particularly black and Hispanic soldiers
got fed up you know fighting and dying
over in Vietnam American jets were
getting shot off by Vietnamese rifles
etcetera and so the war just couldn't
continue right and so it's the same
thing going on in South Africa right so
so on the one hand you have and which is
a very important point I'd like to make
you have South Africa in Namibia
attacking Angola and the South Africans
made Namibia the most militarized area
you know along the border the most
militarized area in the world there are
more weapons more guns more tanks more
more missiles in the world in that
northern part of Namibia so of course
they felt like they were going to just
just again take this town and it would
be very easy but the important thing for
your views to understand is that the
bounds of forces in southern Africa have
totally changed now South Africa cannot
go around with impunity and not expect
to get in be could be in May of 1988
Fidel Castro addressed the special
meeting of the non-aligned countries on
the
of quit or caneva but i may assure you
something like Toria day Africa but in a
momento important history of Africa will
happen moment an today quit Okinawa but
when it is written it will be written
yatta the present we divorced widowed
Quanah Valley and a lot of older also
rough because the powerful South Africa
no flanger you're the superior race say
stray arrow flash on trumpet a soda
tirade or a small piece of territory
there's a little pornography branded by
quite a mulattos the Jammu mulatto Tolo
Cubano we call all the Cubans mulattoes
they say the Angola and mulattoes
is El Caribe from Angola and milligram
photo big fish on your much has been
building up in a yearly intelligent
visible the intelligent power digger say
Estrella which clashed confronted a soda
Torito against a small piece of land
when you meet a white South African gold
rush eesh i'll racist loan you are
dealing a broom the only thing you have
to add it came by showing quit or not
happening with one abiding by showing
what happen with one of our Lincoln and
there's a serious hope that there will
be a negotiated settlement to the
problems of Southern Africa and the
South Africa will at least be put in its
place at the time being and we'll just
have to see if this is a ruse or a third
forced into scaling back on their
operations every time there's been a
peace agreement or peace discussions
with South Africa South Africa has used
it it that that discussion to move more
troops and to rearm and so what's
happening now is South Africa is trying
to find a way to to rearm itself and get
more modern weapons so they can go back
and dangle everybody knows that
everybody and so what they're trying to
do is use this Cuban troops issue as a
guise to do that and you know the end
goal is in the Cubans know what's
happening because they find South Africa
before but because of this major defeat
it causes a very big problem for South
Africa because they're going to have to
eat
Oshie or fight and they can't win by
fighting so they're going to have to
negotiate South Africa want to negotiate
for cash should Africa South Africa
wants to negotiate for Africa South
Africa wants to negotiate in control in
Singapore because it is fighting a very
strong moral being and he had never a
class before and he had never
encountered before
no we're legit tonight before this is
not the year 1975 we had put 400,000
nothingham have you but we did not have
the aviation nothing you're practically
on your hands
anti-aircraft mean practically Allison
Kenny 94 now we have accumulated so many
time around here come on thank God and
sugar we have accumulated around here as
many times more or less than South
Africa has shown my heart but they are
better than we are not Toriyama working
to obtain a military victory we don't
want to have a military victory
quit sooner so la Vida it's enough if
you are you oh yes Victoria money and
any Military Glory really paid in the
earlier you live because we feel
responsible for the life of each and
every of those men they are channels we
are striving for una solución pusta for
a fair solution to the problem Edgar and
Cecil a dignified solution to the
problems which would guarantee the
security olla
for some independence of Namibian
animals Ranger does that with pleasure
in the period of time agreed we will
withdraw our troops conditions the
conditions so that in service can be
really useful of course that entails
Amidala put we have been willing to run
the risk from frontal Cydia and and
serious confrontation manure Diego with
ultra but we have to run such a risk
otherwise there wouldn't be a settlement
from Fidel Castro's opinions from May of
1988 and Kenneth Jones of December of 88
we turn to john stockwell in February of
1989 John's book in search of enemies is
primarily about Angola South Africa is
so-called getting out of Angola
but they did before and they came right
back in again when there was it looked
like they were going to be peace in the
area now looks like the same thing
happened they had their getting the
Cubans to pull out they got their ears
pinned back
they pulled away but now I understood
that I heard where they've actually made
some more armed attacks already : three
weeks ago in London in the interviews
and discussions this is very much what
we were talking about was was what is
the guarantee that South Africa's going
to respect us the Cubans pull out South
Africa pulls out what's going to keep
South Africa is violating every
international law and boundary in
southern Africa what's going to keep
them from going back into Angola how
long will it be before they put their
troops back and an answer was two weeks
yeah and now interestingly enough
Washington's reaction on this of course
Reagan had a big aid program to Savimbi
and Bush has promised to continue it and
obviously is clearly doing so now
Savimbi's pinned down on the border down
there now militarily and it is a little
better off than the Contras are he was
taking a beating so the South African
forces came in to bail him out the u.s.
response they obviously didn't stand up
and say well we happen to be in there in
force with the CIA and we call the South
Africans in there their statement was I
can just remember you know bagging the
task force scribbling away the wording
on the statement you know to put my
newer running tango operation when we
were running their answer was that it
has not been confirmed by any reliable
sources that the South Africans are in
fact back in Angola which they aren't
fact tell our audience that john
stockwell was the CIA officer in charge
of the Angola operation and resigned
after that wrote his book in search of
enemies that began his process of
developing a criticism of the CIA and
has been speaking out as a peace
activist ever since so Angola has
basically been a hot point for the whole
Reagan administration well let's
GEB Angola down just real briefly while
we're on the subject Chester Crocker
Assistant Secretary of State for African
affairs was talking to some of us in the
Africanist progressive side of things
Gerri bender particulate the
international school at USC and
promising that he was going to negotiate
a settlement for a namibia and get the
cubans out of angola and Gerry who my
friend whom I respect enormous Lee said
that you know if you succeed will give
you credit for it publicly and Crocker
succeeded he pounded away and negotiated
away and it took six years and
eventually he worked out a deal where
the South Africans would give Namibia
its independence and the Cubans would go
home and the Cubans are going home and
it's a real deal and the South Africans
are you know there is at least some kind
of farcical independence being given to
Namibia the oversight is it going to
work are the UN forces going to cover it
our death squads going to be left behind
to keep a proxy control you know that
question remains but still bender and
and I supporting him were obliged to say
yes you know Crocker you did you did it
Namibia finally is getting its
independence however in that fascinating
complex deal the Cubans are coming home
South Africa is giving independence to
Namibia and and getting out of Angola
and promising to stay out even but the
United States although arbitrating that
thing did not promise to cease its aid
to Savimbi to destabilize Angola
now that is brass but it's also just
idiotic I mean it just it sort of
confirms your thesis in search of
enemies that the role of the CIA is to
search out enemies to fight wars to
destabilize the world here is a region
that needs stability
there's negotiations to try to stabilize
it and the u.s. keeps supporting these
rebel forces to try to overthrow the
Angola government that led to the oh the
absolutely bizarre situation of the
Cubans there that we're supporting the
Soviet backed Angolan government
protecting the US
multinational corporations I think golf
well had Big O 4 which is whatever the
Cubans were protecting against the CIA
back and goal and rebel forces so
there's not even in US economic interest
when the ZZ naval rising go and sivb was
brought to Washington in the winter of
86 remember he he was he was he dined at
the White House and yet he went on
television promising the aid that he was
being given that he would attack Gulf
oil facilities which facilities had been
built by loans which Reagan had approved
in addition to which he has kept the
central part of Angola frozen and the
Benguela railroad shut and that's as a
year a big clients only economically
viable egress to the sea is that
railroad that we pay Savimbi to keep
shut meanwhile the human horror the Red
Cross counts 55,000 people in Angola who
have been maimed by Savimbi's landlines
and attack and George Bush continues to
support those forces John one of the
analyses that I heard about the the
situation was that there was pressure
within South Africa to get out they
wanted to get out of the Angolan
situation they didn't want to support it
financially and also there were problems
because their soldiers were getting
killed so the United States said okay go
ahead pull out will come in and will
directly supervise the situation and
take care of it so it wasn't a big
victory for the Angolan government or
for Cuba in that respect it was just a
switch of people who were going to
control it well this yeah this is
exactly the point I was trying to make
is that a Crocker playing big arbitrator
and we didn't agree to give the region
peace but it is a fact that knowmaybe is
getting its independence the the South
Africa is going to try to do what we did
to Nicaragua 1933 when we pull the
Marines out and created the guard and
left it behind
with Somoza you know in charge they're
trying to create the same type of a
situation and have a proxy control of it
from the Cuban point of view the
Angolans are being left facing a dire
situation with
be still being funded to destabilize and
the South Africans still coming across
the border and the Cubans coming home
and in Cuba's interests and and it's
it's very difficult to fault them
because they've they sacrificed a lot of
their own and their own capital to the
extent that they can and they're not a
wealthy country to stick up for their
allies and Gulen's but this is the point
at which they could in fact come home
with having accomplished you know a
measurable objective that is Namibia is
independent because of what they did yet
the independence of Namibia or any
country in Africa is precarious because
of the CIA presence there whenever an
independent African nation takes a
socialist Road or a road that goes
against the interests or ideologies of
the CIA they destabilize the government
Kwame Nkrumah wrote a book called class
struggles in Africa that documented the
ways of the CIA overthrew about
twenty-five progressive governments in
Africa including and chromazone Guardian
government the 1960s
so if Namibia takes a route that the CIA
doesn't like they can act to destabilize
it one way or the other so that's really
the precarious situation that all
independent nations in Africa face this
is one of Chomsky's best points is that
when the US when a country tries to
escape our first effort is to bludgeon
them back into the fold and if that
fails as it did in Cuba conspicuously as
it did in Vietnam conspicuously as it's
done in Angola to date and Nicaragua to
date and the fallback is to starve
amount create economic chaos so that
they will not be a positive example to
anyone else to want to break free we
don't want to have a military doctrine
question Isola Vida it's enough to be
what if you are
na VI Victoria mini and any Military
Glory really paid in the earlier you
live because we feel responsible for the
life of each and every of those men they
are sure most we are striving for una
solución poster for a fair solution to
the problem Edgar intitial
a dignified solution to the problems
which would guarantee the studio gonna
force trama independence of nemedia
a little change does that with pressures
in the period of time agreed we will we
brought your troops back on the journey
the conditions so that insolence can be
really Karishma of course that entails
Amidala put poker and we have been
willing to run with confrontation Celia
and and serious confrontation right are
you ready ultra bad we have to run such
a risk
otherwise there wouldn't be a
sedimentary metal can the show but we
are not looking for a confrontation to
obtain a little sundress or novel a
military victory we rather wonder
solution after all so el problema Africa
tried a solution to part of the problem
in Africa petition solution point if the
political solution invitation is
actually a potential enemy is the
independence of Namibia is just candala
or I think that any time we can cookie
go along South Africa would have to
discuss a problem elephant way South
Africa would have to discuss whether to
operate after the extra little moon in
the purple conditions of the world in an
area of the tante
peace disarmament seashell over a South
Africa would happen or the choice rock
such a settlement is attained the time
we can tackle any man from South Africa
to discuss with the entity yundal
problema settlement of the problem of
apartment Africa surrogate finally knows
that it is in a situation of danger were
saying because all those forces Lucia
they had never had to face such an
important school evora and South Africa
try calculating cynical apocalyptic I
will pay we can do something and get
away with my very good if they could go
into Mosul doing some PR they can go
into Zambia
ready to do anything to commit crime in
Lesotho peak I'm going to let total
people wonder if we can go to Botswana
the Kiera Cass appointment Africa can go
it goes no no tiene bah but it doesn't
suffer casualties where they can do away
with it being available now when they
have to face such an important forces
the concentration of human Angolan
forces there now they think it twice
they try to calculate the risk and they
are hurtful they are watchful and that's
where reality of having a penalty and
they know that they are in the face of a
risk there you go go go Rocky and it
will be up to them from where we are or
if they react with a haughtiness I think
they want to confidence Ilona maybe it
could happen that they lose that always
an elephant it happened that the even
lose apartment she soon Africa see only
south africa tape Annika military
military catarrhalis el fin de la / hey
could even be the end with the ramming a
demasiado Devon because that regime is
to wit machado de Ville política meant a
politically tina demasiado beauty o
Premila too many people oppressive
military Cassano we know every me but we
don't want that to happen muna Victoria
Melita want a military mo got a problema
Suresh Volvo despacio
yo Hariyama in lanta shall we think that
then we would be in distress la solución
de problema solution a beret to the
problem of a pyro grande problema
Callaghan also laughing one of the
columns remain it to Africa not only to
Africa but to the world at large but
even if the South Africans and the
Cubans all leave Angolan
that still leaves Savimbi free in the
country still supported by the United
States john stockwell tells us more
about Savimbi south africa's policy is
to keep angola destabilized they've kept
their armies in southern angola for
about 10 years since the 75 thing
they've costed billions of dollars in
damages they raid and bomb
throughout you know up into the central
part of the country with the purpose of
you know of just keeping the country off
balance and keeping it at war and
keeping it from being able to spend its
money to build schools and hospitals and
they supported Savimbi because he can he
can work with his guerrilla forces and
go in and raid and blow things up deep
into the country so they've armed him
and fed him and kept him viable well
superficially you know this is very
appealing this guy is macho plus he is
very charismatic he's a beautiful guy
he's fun he's got these kind of wide
popping eyes and his energy you know and
he's he's got a quality which very few
of these liberation leaders have which
is he likes to fight he likes to be in
the bush with his men and and you know
everywhere else in the world the trouble
like the contra commanders they want to
be in Tegucigalpa in miami and they
don't want to go in there and die in the
hills of northern nicaragua they want to
get in my and Managua and drive the
Mercedes but Savimbi wants to be in
there with his men directing the things
and you know him well if you see out
time with him I guess did you I went
into his lair and recruited him into our
program and then indirectly managed the
lesson with him that charisma and his
light you know is his Yin for the the
contest and he's fighting communists a
Marxist government and then that's
simple we have to support him we have a
moral obligation to support him well
let's give him some money now it gets a
little bit more wrinkly when you add in
the fact that Savimbi isn't about
marxist oh yeah oh yeah the portuguese
colonialist
under a marxist Maoist banner in the
last year we've we've had Savina be
going on television and telling about
his plans if he ever gets into power to
reorganize the country along Marxist
lines now what we're doing and we've
given them the first 15 million dollars
to Savimbi and we got trainers in there
with him right now to train him in his
terrorist activities and this is the man
we would go in and work with now the
congressmen and Senators that I was
talking to with
we'll what are our alternatives and I
was saying that's easy we establish
relations with the government of Angola
which is what Gulf and Rockefeller and
everybody have been saying all along to
provide the diplomatic umbrella and
influence for our corporations that are
doing great business there right now and
then we order South Africa to get her
troops out of the country because they
have a policy of destabilizing this
country and of course we shut off aid to
Savimbi and hopefully starve him out so
that he has a choice of working
peacefully politically in the country
which may be impossible now because
there's so much bloodshed but it was
possible originally or he can go live
somewhere else and play some other game
John what is the response of the rest of
the world toward Angolan you know what
is it ninety-seven percent of the world
condemns this it's we're on the wrong
side for us to be holding hands with and
working with South Africa and the
brutalization of a black African country
is criminal and just totally in politic